viewer discretion is advised
Gabi is our little girl she had
everything going for her so huffing
paint
[Music]
you know what Gabi already can tell you
don't want to be here
Gabi can you make eye contact with me
your family's here because they make eye
contact Gabi
make eye contact you know what let's
just get started all right Rebecca go
ahead I thought it was a boarding school
I got I had no idea Rebecca did you know
that she wanted to have a baby no of
course I didn't know oh my god yeah can
i chime in here real quick she
definitely knew okay I'm gonna stop it
for just a second because I take the
blame but Gabi I want you to know that I
was only trying to protect you
Gabi everyone knows there were so many
unwanted puppies in the world so know
this I want to make this sure this point
is understood you should be thankful
that your doggy womb won't make puppies
that won't not be loved no your womb is
that will I got it now no puppies will
come out of your womb that need let's
just all agree that Rebekah made a
mistake
[Applause]
[Music]
how does that make you feel that Gabby
had unwanted anus licking causes the
first thing I'm gonna see is that image
of a dog coming at my anus no because I
know what you feeling I wish that it had
been my anus instead of yours that those
new yorkese have licked good I think we
made a lot of progress here I'm very
happy with what we did this is um these
are the ones you hope for where the
intervention just goes exactly the way
you hope javi
got out of the hospital she turned to me
and she said daddy I'm gonna take those
demons and I'm gonna turn him into music
and she did just that she put the paint
on the canvas where it belongs
they were selling them like crazy you
can buy one they're beautiful this one
she did with her own feces
[Music]